19h dans un peu plus d'une heure la
patinoire sera plein à deux pas les
jouteurs répètent leurs gammes
vous faites votre action la personne en
face vous annonce une nouvelle qui n'a
rien à voir avec le fait que vous
creusez par exemple je pose ils sont
collégiens et viennent de trappes mans
repas et l'encours et magny les hameaux
et participe au dix huitième cycle mythe
18 ans est aussi la majorité quand on
est jeune ça veut dire quelque chose
majorité ça veut dire aussi quelque
chose dans l'improvisation parce que
c'est c'est le mot qu'utilisent les
arbitres pour donner le point à l'une ou
l'autre équipe
donc c'est vrai que ce site 12h18 pour
nous il a il admis c'est presque un
anniversaire
19h30 dernier moment de détente autour
d'un repas un instant bruyant pour
éliminer la tension un an de travail se
concrétise ce soir là et tous visent la
première place
on appréhende mais ses fins on espère on
va faire de notre mieux en tout cas
c'est plus du plaisir
j'irai l'instant ça va mais je sais que
quand je vais monter sur scène pas la
pression elle va commencer
ça va être compliqué devant des parents
surtout ce que c'est de la première fois
qu'il me voit l'info et ça me stresse
20h30 la soirée est lancée de demi
finale une finale
les premiers à s'affronter les collèges
albert einstein de magny les hameaux et
alexandre dumas de nos repas dans deux
heures le public devra désigner un
vainqueur